so instead of tapping into the
speedforce to access my powers
I created my own judge me to use it I
[Music]
have to warn you Nora
it's a little
hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my flash episode 19 video they did a
whole bunch of stuff from the comics
they finally did the negative speed
force so I'll explain all the Easter
eggs we'll do a top 10 WTF if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the easter egg videos there's a
whole bunch of stuff coming up between
Avengers and game Game of Thrones is on
right now it's crazy we're doing an IMAX
ticket giveaway right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a blast related comment on the
video careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet top
10 WTF here we go number 10
Barry vs iris so they basically pick up
in the moments after last week's episode
with Barry is trying to explain why he
took Nora back to the future she's been
lying to us this whole time she's been
working with the reverse-flash and Barry
isn't having any of it
iris is mostly pissed because he didn't
talk to her before he took Nora back and
she really wants Nora to stay in their
timeline despite the fact that she's
breaking the time-space continuum by
existing in their timeline remember they
usually go by back to the future rules
within the world of the flash in DC
comics at least within the world of the
TV show so there were a lot of Back to
the Future references during the episode
but then she throws flashpoint in his
face like he made decisions like this
all the time without asking other people
the main idea of this argument is that
they're both meant to be about 50% right
so it doesn't really matter what they're
saying cuz they're both kind of taking
crazy pills they didn't really take the
argument to its logical conclusion
because of iris wants Nora to be with
her like the present version of iris so
badly all she has to do is get to making
that baby with Barry and she'll see Nora
in about nine months really if they just
chilled out for about a year or two
Barry would probably go back to the
future to visit her and things would
cool off a little bit but because we're
building in a crisis on Infinite Earths
everything kind of has to blow up in
their faces in the next couple of
episodes number 9 reverse flash gives
Noor the idea to use the negative Speed
Force I'm gonna warn you it's a little
negative so I was so happy that they
finally did this from the comics and
they're actually pulling from Geoff
Johns 2009 flash rebirth comic when
professor zoom created the negative
Speed Force so reverse flash gives a bit
of a tutorial on where it came from why
he created it I was meant to be the
reverse of everything that your father
is and that included creating my own
negative Speed Force that was the
opposite of his so when dropping that
bomb they also read
contextualise a lot of stuff that was
happening during season one but just to
be clear they just did a bunch of
different forces in the forced quest
storyline during the rebirth flash
comics so there's the negative speed
force the still force the sage forced
the strength force the positive speed
force any flash can use any one of those
forces I mean any other meta could use
the other forces too but we're really
just dealing with flashes in the Speed
Force so negative Speed Force positive
speed force doesn't matter whether
you're a good speedster or an evil
speedster like reverse flash you can use
either one but they're playing it a bit
star wars with the light side and the
dark side of the force the negative
Speed Force is driven by very powerful
emotions particularly negative emotions
so I really love the tutorial that he
gives her later in the episode in the
way that he narrates in how that speech
is very different from the speech that
he gives to Norah when she's trying to
teach her how to phase like it was a
really positive speech you're one with
the Speed Force you're one with
everything but the negative Speed Force
is all about being sad angry and all
alone in the world being just so welled
up with emotion that you want to explode
and kill everything so that creepy smile
on his face when he tells her about it
I'm gonna warn you it's gonna be a
little negative just gives you an idea
that he's excited about what's gonna
happen but the way the show's playing it
makes it sound like he's definitely
manipulating her because now a couple
different characters are like oh yeah he
is definitely messing with Nora's head
but because of some of the twists at the
end of the episode it's hard to tell how
much he's genuinely trying to help Norah
and how much he's just doing this to
create a way for himself to escape I'll
talk about that in a second because I
think that has a lot to do with what's
going on with Barry in reverse-flash
between the two of them since the last
time that they met with each other in
the future but number 8 future Grace
Secada
steals young grace from her hospital bed
Barry says could things get any worse
which is obviously the worst possible
thing that you could say in a genre show
like this
that's the minute that things get really
really bad even though it seems like it
had something to do with the atomiser at
the end of the episode I think the other
practical reason for taking her from the
hospital is to prevent team flash from
just using the nuclear option of waking
young grace up out of her coma causing
older Grace Secada to just vanish into
the timestream that would be a really
easy way to defeat her
but number 7 there's something worse
that Barry prophesied was icicle coming
back ransacking Caitlin's mother
lab for the cryo atomizer so that he
could create another killer frost in
Caitlin's mother and they could be like
a cold family together there were a lot
of funny moments between her and her
mother but you kind of saw their arc
during the episode Caitlin's mother used
to be kind of an antagonist to her but
now they want her to be her friend and
they trying to build that bond between
them so that when her mother eventually
turns into another killer frost persona
or another icicle persona she can be a
villain for the show because they killed
off icicle during the episode there was
a very big pizza easter egg that you
guys probably spotted if you read text
upside down
that's Milgram in McFarland pizza
obviously todd mcfarlane from spawn fame
he also worked on a lot of Marvel a lot
of DC titles he was one of the people
that popularized venom al Milgram was
one of the people that helped create the
firestorm character with Jerry Conway so
number six iris and Ralph go back to the
future with a lot of back to the future
references this is a little bit like
iris in Reverse flash during the recent
rebirth comics last year so either last
year or the year before they just
brought back eobard thawne reverse flash
in the new flash rebirth title and as
part of that storyline he takes iris to
the Future to show her what happens to
her and Barry's children this is very
post-apocalyptic future central city
everything looks like it's gone to [ __ ]
and their children the tornado twins
look like they're full-blown evil so
reverse-flash is just sort of taunting
Barry in iris with this it was also this
version of iris because they rebooted
everything learning that Barry was the
flash for the first time so they weren't
even a couple at this point in the
comics there's an 88 miles an hour
reference that Ralph gives off they're
using Savatage Speed Force gun to open a
wormhole and obviously using you Barth
ons time capsule to travel back to the
future but number 5 reverse flash gives
Nora the most WTF negative speed force
tutorial like I said the speech that he
gave Barry and Nora separately when he
was teaching them to face was really
positive it gets you really jazzed up
but the inspirational speech that he
gives to Nora when she's trying to
access the negative Speed Force which is
so messed up as cool as that is side
note that also gives you an idea for the
way reverse-flash feels about himself
relative to Barry Allen he feels all
alone in the world he's really upset
about it so in the comics reverse-flash
comes back during the 2009 flash rebirth
he'd been trapped in the Speed Force
but what he
does is to create the negative speed
force is that he sort of reverse
engineers the accident that gave Barry
powers they got a little fast and loose
with the logic of it all during that era
in the comics but in present day they
just say that the negative Speed Force
is one of many different forces that
people can access so if you're wondering
if there's negative Speed Force wormhole
aliens like they're living beings in the
Speed Force that exert their will when
Barry does things that they don't want
or when they want Barry to do something
specific just because reverse-flash
created the negative Speed Force doesn't
necessarily mean that there are now
negative Speed Force wormhole aliens it
doesn't quite work that way so they're
playing a little fast and loose so I
wouldn't try to put too many holes in
that but number four Ralph and iris
visit reverse-flash in prison He Who
Shall Not Be Named Volta Mort Harry
Potter reference there's an
advertisement for elongated man's
jingled soda on the back of the guards
magazine he makes a Silence of the Lambs
reference when he says Hannibal
speedster talking about Hannibal Lecter
aka reverse-flash is messed up as it is
that iris has come to talk to him she at
least realizes that he's manipulating
Norah
even though probably the most shocking
conclusion that she comes to is that he
genuinely cares about her and it's
really hard to tell how much of that is
actually genuine emotion that he feels
for Norah and how much of it is him just
manipulating her to get himself out of
this situation where he's gonna die as
the countdown clock reaches zero but
number three killer frost versus icicle
so they have a battle there's a lot like
the killer frost flash battle from
season three with her using her ice
bridge to just glide through the sky
they do a much bigger version of that
because icicle has all the same powers
that she has I'm not super invested in
her relationship with her father even
like they had a couple nice moments the
way they wrote it maybe if they'd been
building that for the last couple of
seasons it'd be a little bit different
but the Thomas persona prevents icicle
from killing killer frost so they get a
nice moment but then obviously grace
winds up killing him later in the
episode so like I said they're sort of
replacing him with a potential future
version of icicle in her mother or
future killer frost whatever you want to
call her mother's evil persona but
number two the big surprise at the end
of the episode is is that the special
vial of her mother's DNA turns white me
that she will eventually at some point
either in a future episode or a future
season manifest an evil persona whatever
they want to
all that there were a lot of people that
thought that maybe danielle Panabaker
was leaving the flash at the end of the
season everybody's wondering if cisco is
gonna leave the show if maybe tom
cavanagh is gonna leave the show so
reverse-flash in all that harrison wells
will leave the show but if they're
setting up Caitlin's mother to be a
really big villain for her because now
that they're all close by the end of the
episode like hey maybe we'll hang out
sometime I want you to be in my life it
makes more sense that she turns evil so
she becomes a much more meaningful
villain for Caitlin in a future season I
don't think they would do that with only
a couple episodes left to go so it seems
like more of a season six type of twist
where we see that evil mother persona
but that would imply that danielle
panabaker is gonna stay on the flash TV
show so I don't know if she's going to
be leaving anytime in the future before
season seven because most of the main
cast are signed for seven seasons on the
show but every once in a while an actor
will be killed off early or they'll ask
to be let out of their contract early
which it sounds like maybe is gonna
happen with Cisco he wasn't even in this
episode and I don't recall them having a
really good reason for why he wasn't
around so the fact that Cisco seems to
be absent from so many episodes this
season does imply that he is eventually
gonna leave the show but number one WTF
just as Barry and iris are making up
with each other for their big argument
earlier in the episode and negative
flash Nora comes back to the past
poisoned with negative Speed Force which
is actually some of the fanfiction that
I wrote before season 5 started before
we knew that Nora was gonna be an only
child and we still thought they were
gonna do tornado twins I was like
wouldn't it be cool if their twins were
poisoned by negative Speed Force and
Barry had to save them or they got to be
villains for part of the season because
it'd be much more meaningful for Team
flash if the people that they were
trying to stop doing all these crazy
evil things were their biological
children so they're kind of doing that
with Nora the last couple of episodes
but because it's episode 19 this week
and there's only 22 episodes in the
season obviously this isn't gonna last
for that much longer when iris said that
she thinks that reverse-flash cares
about Nora the same way that Barry does
like a daughter that actually seems like
a pretty big twist the end of the season
where as you would normally expect Nora
to break reverse-flash out of prison
before he gets executed now what they
might do because Barry is trying to be
more understanding of Nora understanding
of iris being more empathetic with
villains that was the
pointed the cicada storyline like let's
try to help him let's not try to kill
him even though he's been killing a
whole lot of people big twist this
season
maybe berry helps reverse-flash escaped
from prison giving him a reprieve like
I'm gonna give you a chance because
you've tried to help my daughter so much
and it seems like you're turning over a
new leaf but the thing about the future
crisis on Infinite Earths a newspaper is
that it said that reverse-flash was
leading an army of shadow demons so
either they changed that and
reverse-flash helps them during crisis
on Infinite Earths in the next crossover
or he double-crosses berry at the end of
the season after berry helps him escape
so let me know in the comments clearly
reverse-flash is not gonna die at the
end of the season what do you think
happens to get him out of that prison
what's happening later this week is that
obviously avengers endgame is hitting
theaters and they're doing the biggest
episode of Game of Thrones in the show's
history so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll get all
those videos but there's gonna be a
whole bunch of big stuff happening this
weekend so make sure you stay alive so
that you have a chance to see it all
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post new DC but click here for my
non-spoilery Avengers and game review
and click here for the trailer for that
next huge episode of Game of Thrones
season aid thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]